[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen man
einen schönen guten abend am tag nach
dem em-finale nonnen robert
robert ist auch ein schöner war ein
toller fußballer am knapper sieg der
engländer will dazu
ein hoffnungsschimmer in krisenzeiten
der erste frachter mit mehr als 26.000
tonnen getreide bericht im ukrainischen
odessa auf
nachwuchs dringend gesucht obwohl viele
arbeitgeber mit extras wie einem platz
im wohnheim und sportmöglichkeiten
ködern bleiben mehr als 230.000
ausbildungsstellen unbesetzt und
stolz und auch ein bisschen enttäuscht
die deutschen vize europameisterinnen
kehren heim tausende fans bereiten ihnen
einen begeisternden empfang in frankfurt
[Applaus]
bis zuletzt war die sorge groß dass das
abkommen platzen könnte bevor es richtig
losgeht jetzt die gute nachricht das
erste schiff mit blockierten getreide
exporten konnte aus der ukraine ablegen
26.000 tonnen getreide sind seit heute
morgen unterwegs richtung libanon vom
ukrainischen odessa aus geht es über
einen korridor zunächst nach istanbul wo
and teams die frächter kontrollieren
damit keine waffen in die ukraine hinein
oder heraus geschmuggelt werden wie
dringend das getreide benötigt wird
betont heute nochmal die un
flüchtlingshilfe lieferausfälle treffen
vor allem die hungernden in
krisenregionen hat im hafen von odessa
sind mittlerweile 16 weitere schiffe
bereits zum auslaufen anne brühl
berichtet
michael billy liegen 15.000 tonnen
getreide auf dem hof die neue ernte
jetzt soll das alles so schnell wie
möglich zum hafen
wir können mit dem verschiffen morgen
anfangen dass es kein problem für uns
wie die annahme läuft es die frage es
gibt so viele die ihr getreide loswerden
wollen in der ukraine gibt es zu viel
getreide im moment
die rad sony war am morgen das erste
schiff das mit 26.000 tonnen mais an
bord in richtung libanon in see stach
morgen abend soll das schiff den
bosporus passieren wenn denn alles gut
geht auf der reise in odessa haben daran
viele ihre zweifel
nein ich vertraue russland nicht
besonders die ukraine hat keine wahl wir
müssen unser getreide verkaufen und
liefern
das weiß auch russland und das macht die
situation in kriegszeiten so gefährlich
für die ukraine
gut 80 millionen tonnen getreide warten
darauf verschifft zu werden dass es die
gesamte diesjährige ernte und 20
millionen tonnen aus dem vergangenen
jahr der agrarsektor ist entscheidend
für die wirtschaft hier jedes schiff das
den hafen verlässt bringt geld in die
kasse der ukraine
michael billy hofft trotzdem dass der
start der getreideexporte eine erste
rückkehr zur normalität sein könnte oder
früher oder später enden alle kriege
einmal es kann in einem monat passieren
oder in einem jahr wir kennen natürlich
auch geschichten in denen es 100 jahre
gedauert hat aber wir sind im 21
jahrhundert und hoffen dass dieser krieg
bald zu ende sein wird seine
sonnenblumen kann er in 20 tagen ernten
ein großteil davon ist auch für den
export bestimmt
wegen der hohen inflation und den
gestiegenen energiepreisen kaufen den
menschen in deutschland deutlich weniger
ein mit dramatischen folgen für den
einzelhandel egal ob lebensmittel oder
textilien im juni gingen die verkäufe
inflationsbereinigt um 8,8 prozent
zurück im vergleich zum vorjahr das gab
es seit 28 jahren nicht auch der online
handel blieb davon nicht verschont wie
das statistische bundesamt mitteilte und
die energiepreise sind auch so hoch weil
russland den gas- hand immer weiter
zudreht die eu will sich daher auf das
schlimmste vorbereiten so
kommissionspräsidentin von allein ab
heute tritt deshalb einen notfallplan in
kraft und der bedeutet jedes eu land
soll bis ende märz nächsten jahres 15
prozent gas einsparen wie deutschland
das schaffen will hat sich einer
hebestreit angeschaut am beispiel der
stadtwerke kiel
rund 70.000 haushalte und unternehmen
werden vom ostufer der kieler förde mit
strom und fernwärme versorgt eines der
modernsten gas wärme kraftwerke europas
ersetzt seit 2009 10 das alte
kohlekraftwerk direkt nebenan die
bundesregierung möchte erdgas sparen und
reaktiviert alte kraftwerke das aber ist
in kiel nicht möglich wir haben den
kohleausstieg bereits vollzogen wir
haben keine andere möglichkeit als die
fernwärme über das über solche
kraftwerke zu errichten über hochmoderne
hocheffiziente kraftwerke die auf gas
basieren kein gas keine fernwärme
weshalb ein deutscher ausstieg aus der
gasverstromung schwierig wäre die
explodierenden preise allerdings machen
erdgas gründen nervös versorger halten
jährliche mehrbelastungen für strom und
fernwärme zusammen von 1500 bis 2500
euro hier vier personen haushalt für
möglich was aber bei mieterinnen und
mietern schon erkennbar ist sind große
ängste kann ich mir das noch leisten
kann ich noch wohnen wie es das sage ich
jetzt mal mit einer familie mit kleinen
kinder mit säuglingen kann ich komme ich
da mit denen sozusagen warm über den
winter
vermieter drängen auf staatliche
unterstützung für mieter und
hauseigentümer nicht auf forderungen der
versorger sitzen bleiben viel besser
wäre es wenn die bundesregierung den
mietern und bei helfen würde das hat
auch während der korona krise sehr gut
funktioniert in den sozialen
sicherungssystemen zb dem wohngeld strom
und wärme kunden sollten auf jeden fall
jetzt schon geld für die kommenden
abrechnungen ansparen
wie können wir unsere energieversorgung
sichern droht ohne atomkraft ein
blackout darum geht es bei zdf heute
live um 20 15 auf unseren social media
kanälen und in der app
trotz der aktuellen weltlage will
außenministerin berbalk das ziel der
atomaren abrüstung nicht aus den augen
verlieren das sagte sie bei ihrer
ankunft in new york wo sie zur stunde an
einer konferenz der vereinten nationen
zur bilanz des atomwaffensperrvertrages
teilnimmt zum auftakt des treffens rief
un-generalsekretär görisch zur
abschaffung aller atomwaffen auf
us-außenminister blinken sagte die
vereinigten staaten seien bereit mit
allen atommächten zusammenzuarbeiten
auch mit china und
bei den un in new york sitzt für uns
elmar theveßen emma es geht also um
atomare abrüstung wie wahrscheinlich
sind danach fortschritte
extrem unwahrscheinlich ministerin
baerbock hat hier vorhin gesagt es sind
harte zeiten
wenn ein krieg mitten in europa tobt
dann sind vertrauensbildende maßnahmen
natürlich sehr schwierig um 3 1 testet
nordkorea immer wieder seine raketen für
atomwaffen iran versucht an atomwaffen
heranzukommen und vor diesem hintergrund
so sagte die ministerin sei es besonders
wichtig dass man noch einmal klar macht
dass man abrüsten muss dass man kontroll
mechanismen braucht da sogar prüfung wie
nuklearmaterial in der welt herum
vagabundiert dass es unter kontrolle ist
aber abrüstungsmaßnahmen sind momentan
eben auch nicht in sicht weil die großen
die wichtigen staaten die usa russland
und china momentan spannungen haben
miteinander nicht reden jedenfalls nicht
zwischen russland und den usa was
abrüstungsverträge angeht und es gibt
eben die spannungen mit china weil china
drohungen ausstoß gegenüber taiwan
angesichts des besuches der sprecherin
des amerikanischen repräsentantenhauses
nancy pelosi die wohl morgen taiwan
besuchen wird und ich habe die
ministerin danach gefragt und sie hat
noch mal sehr klar gemacht es gilt
natürlich auch hier wie gegenüber
russland das ein großer nachbar seinen
kleinen nachbarn auf keinen fall
überfallen darauf das sei nicht
akzeptabel und das gelte auch eben für
china gegenüber seinem kleinen nachbarn
taiwan dankeschön party wissen aus new
york
wichtiges urteil vom europäischen
gerichtshof mit regelungen zum
familiennachzug von geflüchteten
verstößt deutschland gegen eu-recht der
nachtzug dürfe nicht deshalb verwehrt
werden weil ein minderjähriges kind
während eines laufenden verfahrens
volljährig geworden sei urteilten die
richterinnen und richter in luxemburg
hintergrund sind zwei fälle in denen
deutsche behörden syrern die
zusammenführung mit ihren familien
verweigert hatten
heute vor genau acht und 70 jahren
begann in warschau der aufstand gegen
die nazi besatzer in polens hauptstadt
gedachten die menschen an mehreren orten
der opfer
auf befehl hitlers hatten deutsche
truppen den aufstand brutal
niedergeschlagen geschätzt bis zu
200.000 menschen starben polens
präsident erinnerte im stadtteil wolle
an die greueltaten
kriegsverbrechen dürfen nicht ungestraft
bleiben betonte duda
es ist ein fall der über österreich
hinaus für schlagzeilen sorgt eine
ärztin bekommt von krone leugnern und
impfgegnern morddrohungen und hass
nachrichten sie fühlt sich offenbar von
der polizei in den behörden nicht
genügend gegen die angriffe geschützt
die ärztin nimmt sich dann wohl selbst
das leben heute wird ihr mit mahnwachen
gedacht was christian ullrich berichtet
trauer um eine engagierte ärztin die
sich das leben nahm wohl weil der hass
im netz auf sie zu groß geworden war
lisa-maria kellermeier war immer wieder
für die korona impfung eingetreten und
hatte auf twitter gezeigt wie corona
leutner eine zufahrt zu einem
krankenhaus blockierten vor allem corona
leugner impfgegner und rechtsradikale
darunter wohl auch deutsche machten ihr
daraufhin in sozialen medien und
drohbriefen das leben zur hölle drohten
ihr und ihrem praxisteam mit dem tod es
braucht für mich bedingungen ein
sicheres umwelt unter dem ich den
betrieb wieder aufnehmen kann das heißt
entweder polizeischutz oder eine
kostenübernahme für die
sicherheitsmassnahmen weil sie sich von
der polizei im stich gelassen fühlte
schloss sie vor einem monat ihre praxis
die polizei sagt man habe alles getan
ein polizei sprecher behauptete gar die
ärztin wolle sich wichtig machen ein
bekannter schildert den druck den sie
verspürt haben muss eine massive
bedrohung von seiten der krone maßnahme
leuten erinnern und leugner
mit durchaus sehr persönlichen angriffen
die sie ernst genommen hat und wo sie
gemeint hat die behörden nehmen das in
ihrer wahrnehmung nicht ernst genug
politiker reagierten bestürzt auf den
suizid ärztin politikwissenschaftler
peter filzmaier sieht bei politik und
behörden jedoch große hilflosigkeit
leider ist der tragische suizid
kellermeier ein symbol für viele fälle
leugnung wissenschaftlicher
medizinischer realitäten wüste angriffe
im fall von meinungsäußerungen und in
der tat bis hin zu beschimpfungen aber
auch matronen am abend soll es auch vor
dem wiener stephansdom eine
gedenkveranstaltung für lisa maria
kellermeier geben
im fall der toten schülerin eileen
verdichten sich die hinweise auf ein
gewaltverbrechen
ein dringend tatverdächtiger mann sitzt
in untersuchungshaft der wegen eines
sexualdelikts bereits vorbestraft ist
nach polizeiangaben war der 29 jährige
am freitag in frankfurt am main
festgenommen worden am selben tag hatten
ermittler die leiche des mädchens in
hessen gefunden rund 300 kilometer
nördlich ihres elternhauses eine hin
galt zuvor mehr als eine woche lang als
vermisst
für den schiffbau in mecklenburg
vorpommern war die insolvenz der mv
werfen im januar ein schwerer schlag
gegen korona hatte das kerngeschäft der
bau von kreuzfahrtschiffen erstmal keine
zukunft nun haben alle drei werften neue
besitzer den standort wismar kaufte ein
u boot bauer des thyssenkrupp konzerns
in stralsund will die stadt das gelände
in einen gewerbepark umwandeln und ab
heute gehört die rostocker werft dem
bund künftig sollen hier schiffe der
bundesmarine repariert werden und muss
wach der stützpunkt der marine bei
rostock warnemünde der neue arbeitgeber
für die schiffbauer der mv werften
direkt gegenüber künftig sollen sie hier
fregatten und korvetten reparieren vor
zwei jahren waren es noch fast 1000
werftarbeiter jetzt könnten 500
weiterbeschäftigt werden und ich gehe
davon aus dass das eingehalten wird und
das ist im gegensatz zu vorher zwar
weniger aber besser als das was passiert
wäre wenn die nicht gekommen wenn dann
werde ich nichts mehr los gewesen dann
wäre das ding leer gewesen zunächst
müssen jedoch die reste des größten
kreuzfahrtschiff der welt beseitigt
werden die durch corona verursachte
weltweite kreuzfahrt krise zwang die mv
werften in die insolvenz für die fast
fertige global dream die am standort
wismar liegt gibt es bis heute keinen
käufer das verteidigungsministerium will
sich aktuell nicht äußern zur übernahme
der werft verweist auf eine
pressemeldung von anfang juli mangelnde
kapazitäten und lange liegezeiten sollen
nun der vergangenheit angehören mit dem
erwerb sehe ich die große möglichkeit
die einsatzbereitschaft für den bereich
marine signifikant zu erhöhen rund ein
drittel des 65 hektar großen geländes
soll zivil genutzt werden etwa für den
bau von offshore plattformen für den
insolvenzverwalter ist der verkauf an
die marine ein guter deal ich glaube
jetzt ein sehr guter tag insbesondere
für die menschen vor ort für die
bundesrepublik deutschland auch ich
glaube es eine ganz tolle lösung und vor
allem bietet ist jetzt mal langfristig
eine perspektive von da bin ich sehr
froh über das ergebnis die marine
übernimmt aus der rostocker schiffbau
werft wird ein militärischer
reparaturbetrieb der
langjährige korrespondent des zdf
joachim sauer ist im alter von 82 jahren
gestorben
chefredakteur frey würdigte ihn als
brückenbauer zwischen ost und west java
moderierte kennzeichen d leitete auch
die zdf studios in berlin und wien
unvergessen sein bericht vom abbau der
grenzanlagen zwischen ungarn und
österreich im mai 89 als einziger
westdeutsche journalist vor ort erkannte
er sofort die tragweite ein historischer
ein bewegender augenblick vor über 40
jahren wurde quer durch europa die
absperrung errichtet die der britische
staatsmann winston churchill den
eisernen vorhang nannte
heute beendet ungarn an dieser stelle
die gewaltsame teilung von ost und west
erste august viele junge menschen
starten heute ins berufsleben nach dem
schulabschluss beginnt die ausbildung
aber es fehlt an bewerberinnen und
bewerbern mittlerweile müssen sich und
die unternehmen so einiges einfallen
lassen wie zum beispiel eine günstige
wohnung über die suche nach dem
nachwuchs florian kojak
kaum ist ein ausbildungsjahrgang fertig
startet schon der nächste doch der ist
kleiner als erhofft bei diesem elektro
bauer im thüringischen schleiz 40
auszubildende waren das ziel nur halb so
viele fangen an dabei wird ihnen hier
schon einiges geboten
dazu bis zu finden ist für uns wirklich
eine ganz große herausforderung wir
helfen den lehrlingen bei wohnungssuche
bei behördengängen bei schulischen
leistungen unterstützen wir und wir
haben den ball geschaut dass
lehrlingswohnheim noch der nachwuchs
fehlt in vielen branchen bundesweit
bleiben immer mehr ausbildungsstellen
unbesetzt knapp 100 44.000 waren es im
juli vor zehn jahren heute sind es mehr
als 200 33.000 die gaga stärken sind
eher kleiner geworden ein größerer teil
entscheidet sich für ein abitur das
heißt es gibt eine große bringschuld
dann auch von wirtschaft und
gesellschaft die möglichen
ausbildungsberufe
attraktiv für die jugendlichen zu machen
für den erzieherberuf ist das mit dem
modellprojekt pia bereits gelungen der
praxis integrierten ausbildung ihre
vorteile nur drei jahre mehr praxis und
vor allem auch eine ausbildungsvergütung
seien eben noch weiter zu bestreiten
umsetzungen job haushalt schwierig dann
wird es vielleicht ohne geld dazustehen
da die nachfrage deutlich die
verfügbaren plätze übersteigt kann pia
vielleicht auch für andere branchen
vorbild sein um mit neuen wegen wieder
mehr junge menschen für klassische
ausbildungsberufe zu begeistern
mit dieser rolle hat nichelle nichols
fernsehgeschichte geschrieben als
lieutenant uhura im raumschiff
enterprise nun ist sie im alter von 89
jahren gestorben
mitte der 60er war ihr partner an bord
mehr als ungewöhnlich eine
afroamerikanerin spielt eine
führungsoffizieren
ihr kuss mit captain kirk war 1968 der
erste zwischen einer schwarzen und einem
weißen us-fernsehen skandal und
meilenstein zugleich
und jetzt der fußball-em norbert das war
gestern das finale gestern sowie das
finale wm finale der männer damals 1966
das war ja auch im wembley stadion ein
duell auf augenhöhe england gewinnt und
wieder eine umstrittene schiri
entscheidung gegen deutschland das dfb
team einfach mitreißend ja und
hinreißend heute der empfang für sie in
frankfurt
kein pokal kein neunter em-titel und
trotzdem reichlich begeisterung in der
heimat dank eines sehenswerten teams das
über die enttäuschung nur langsam
hinwegkommt
wie gestern eben die niederlage dann
zustande kamen und ja wir uns leider am
ende nicht belohnt haben ohne die
kurzfristig verletzte torgarant
alexandra popp muss die dfb-elf
auskommen und ohne elfmeter in der
ersten hälfte der nach einem strafraum
handspiel von englands kapitän in
williams und nicht gegeben wird so kann
england durch ella tun nach der pause in
führung gehen lina magull gelingt der
ausgleich zur verlängerung in der dann
das lange bein von chloe kelly das 2 1
und england den titel bringt dem
deutschen team sieht man die
enttäuschung in frankfurt kaum noch an
der turnierauftritt insgesamt soll
wirken und einen letzten wunsch fragt
die werte die wir wirklich vorgelebt
haben trat die werte in unserer
gesellschaft dann wären wir ein stück
weit besser und wir haben sie verdient
der letzte eindruck wird festgehalten
die em als erfolg auch ohne titel
nächste chance nächstes jahr dann ist wm
ja markus wolsiffer auf dem frankfurter
römer die party ist vorbei aber was
bleibt von dieser frauen fußball
euphorie
ja das ist eine der zentralen fragen wir
stehen tatsächlich auf dem rathaus
balkon vor fast genau drei stunden sind
sie hier raus gekommen und das war ein
ohrenbetäubender lärm großer jubel ja
was bleibt der große wunsch ist die
euphorie mitzunehmen macht die stadien
voll das haben sie hier den fußball fans
zugerufen und ich denke die botschaft
kam auch an es geht darum den
frauenfußball weiter zu stärken auch die
frauenfußball bundesliga und da gibt es
bereits ein positives signal das
auftaktspiel der frauenfußball
bundesliga findet mitte september im
frankfurter waldstadion statt also
vermutlich großer kulisse vor ort aber
auch vor den tv-geräten denn es ist im
freetv zu sehen insofern das ist ein
signal dass jetzt langfristig mit leben
gefüllt werden muss danke markus
wolsiffer
ja natürlich wurden heute auch die
europameisterin in london gebührend
gefeiert nämlich auf dem trafalgar
square nach einer rauschenden partynacht
lassen sich die lyoness ist von
tausenden fans bejubeln schließlich ist
es ja nicht nur ihr erster em finalsieg
sondern auch der erste internationale
fußball titel für england seit eben
darauf kann england echt stolz sein kann
gleich beim wetter es wird sehr heiß wer
hat es denn terry für sie das heute
journal können sie um 21 45 sehen mit
mitri sirin am morgen begrüßt er sich
hier an dieser stelle auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
extreme dürre hitze waldbrände die
klimakrise ist in diesem sommer hautnah
zu spüren und die hitze setzt sich fort
mit diesem bekannten wettermuster hitze
über spanien morgen bis 45 grad die
wandelt in den nächsten tagen richtung
frankreich danach deutschland und es
sind wieder 40 grad im südwesten zu
erwarten der kommenden nacht gibt es
südlich der donau schauer und gewitter
sonst ist es trocken und die
temperaturen sinken auf 7 grad ganz im
norden deutschlands und 17 grad im
südwesten
morgen dann ganz im norden einige
schauer ansonsten aber überwiegend
trocken nach osten hin sonnig und im
südwesten auch die wolken sind harmlos
es fällt kein regen und ansonsten auch
mal kompaktere wolken bei höchsten
temperaturen von 22 grad an der ostsee
hier also erträglicher als im südwesten
mit 32 grad oder am niederrhein 30 grad
die kommenden tage temperaturen steigen
mittwoch bis 37 grad viel sonnenschein
donnerstag bis zu 40 grad im südwesten
deutschlands richtung berlin ebenfalls
37 grad drin und freitag krachte es mit
neuen gewittern ein schöner amt